a small city has become one of the
biggest battles in Russia's war in
Ukraine Moscow has sent tens of
thousands of troops to of diva in the
Eastern denet region but Ukraine says
many of those men have been killed on
the battlefield in what's looking like a
repeat of the deadly fight for bakut
earlier this year there's not really
anything left of M and that's the same
as Bak was here's why Russia is
determined to take of Diva no matter the
cost
capturing of Diva would allow Russia to
tighten its grip on the denk
region the city is located just over 30
Mi south of bahmut but eviva is more
significant to Moscow because it is
close to denk city which has been held
by Russia since
2014 as with bahmut controlling of Diva
won't give Russia any significant
military gains but it would be a
propaganda win for Moscow something
Ukrainian President vadir zinski says
his Russian counterpart Vladimir Putin
needs heading into
winter seing of Diva would allow Putin
to claim that the momentum in the war is
back with Moscow Putin after the initial
failure to take Kiev announced that
taking the dkan luhans region was the
priorities and symbolically it would
show that they're still moving forward
Russia is pouring large numbers of
troops into its assault and of Diva just
like in bahmut earlier this year and
also as in bahmut Ukraine says this has
cost Moscow thousands of men and dozens
of armored vehicles yet they've hardly
Advanced for the Russians a war of
attrition favors them a high casualty
War which ran favors that and they've
been more willing to just throw bodies
at an area to try to take it than
Ukraine has the Russian Ministry of
Defense didn't respond to a request for
comment about its assault on a divka but
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
said his forces were conducting active
defense along the whole front
line for Ukraine as with bahmut is a
symbol of
resistance the city has been a Russian
Target since 2014 when Moscow first
launched a covert in invasion of
Ukraine's denk and Lans
regions while Russian forces are largely
in control of the denk region of Diva
remains a Ukrainian stronghold but ke
has not placed as much rhetorical
importance on the city as it did with
bahmut you had seninsky in his nightly
addresses talking about bmud basically
every night for months and months and
months and he's not doing that with
thatd in the same way he has not made it
a symbolic political point to to hold on
to
it ke was criticized for its decision to
defend bahmut rather than retreat with
critics saying Ukraine had taken too
many
casualties I wouldn't be surprised if
ukrainians are more willing to give up
abka and I don't know that that they're
going to be so willing to throw so many
men at it as they were with
Bak analysts say Russia's heavy losses
May undermine moscow's long term
offensive capabilities as winter
approaches seizing control of new
territory no matter how small would be
seen as a win in moscow's eyes that's as
both sides have struggled to seize any
new territory this year after troops
spent months building up defensive lines
last winter it's been very difficult
this year for either side to
significantly move the line and it looks
like that trend is continuing in abiva
and we'll see if that changes but it
doesn't look like it so
far